remote-controlled helicopters pool darts
and tabletop sucker these are just a few
of the many disciplines facing these
olympians in the making a lot of
competition you have to prove yourself I
hate it when the guys beat the boss
wouldn't fantastic sit stuff I need a
beer I should've had more sons than
daughters it'll be more fun playing
let's turn back the clock a few hours
the store has just closed for business
for the day and now opens its doors for
the older generation the latest recruits
to the arena are a group of firefighters
the evenings proceedings are run by
Heinz Lehman he won a government
innovation award for his pioneering idea
Suazo scott monument and elderly gent
said he'd love to be locked in here for
a night and I said okay we can do that
and the concept has really taken off
since its launch four years ago the
group face offs are normally packed to
capacity yeah leap self I hope you guys
love it they come in here with no idea
of what to expect and then something
just clicks in us men it's difficult to
explain there's no zoning a 14-10 the
rules are easy the men are split into
groups of four and then get down to
business on the trek the table and the
carpet
there are a total of eleven stages on
the road to glory or ignominy
participants pay a 30 euro entry fee for
the privilege the dividends are
priceless it's about mens primeval
instinct ambitions beating your opponent
and being the best that's what being a
man means it's madelyn as a young boy
you survey all the store shelves and
don't know what you're allowed and what
you're going to get for christmas and
now there were bigger boys you can have
it all couldn't I just no boys in their
toy is an old adage that the games
industry is now picking up on the
phenomenon is particularly evident on
the internet the Carrera slot car brand
now has a special online section for
real men for German fans Lego has it's
very own website catering to the
grown-ups and model railways have always
been an excuse for dads to play of
course leederville isn't sure about I
see Putin came in like thirty percent of
sales are now online Yvonne that's a
real problem for retailers we feel the
effect so we're happy for this
additional money earner we get over 60
men here on one evening and we have a
great time or enjoy meeting but I'm
Troon Rd level of them
the gaming session lasts a grueling four
hours but guys dial refreshments are
available at the stroke of midnight it's
time to tally the points have announced
the winner attorney by day
all-conquering champ by night his prize
is a matchbox car as a memento of his
night of triumph I thought it was great
now I want to hear some appreciation
how's everything [ __ ] it's a lot of fun
I'll be back Heinz Lehman is happy to
his guys nights have built up a cult
following in Hanover and the trend
they've said is catching on big time
across Germany